the white house plans a big rollout
today for a long awaited plan to rebuild
u.s. infrastructure but it may be
overshadowed by the cloud over two
presidential aides Rob Porter and David
Sorenson who left the White House over
allegations they abused their wives
president Trump's top aides defended the
response to the charges yesterday but
mixed messages from the president and
the timeline leading to Rob Porter's
resignation are raising new questions
those questions focus on how the White
House chief of staff and top lawyer
handled the allegations many months ago
when they became aware of them and
whether the chief of staff was truthful
in explaining how he handled the
situation major Garrett is at the White
House major good morning good morning
president Trump has been publicly
supportive of his former top aide Rob
port or even though we are told in
private he has recently referred to
Porter as quote a sick puppy and there's
now a concerted White House effort to
shield chief of staff John Kelly from
the fallout by portraying Porter as
someone who deceived Kelly and others
John Kelly's doing an outstanding job
White House officials threw their
support behind chief of staff John Kelly
Sunday hoping to counter reports the
president was considering replacing him
he has full confidence in his current
chief of staff general john kelly budget
director Mick Mulvaney answered charges
the White House failed to take domestic
abuse allegations seriously I don't
think we have a lacks attitude I think
what you saw happen this week major was
was completely reasonable and normal but
the White House put out statements of
support for Porter several hours after
the photos of abuse surfaced and Kelly
was told by White House Counsel Don
McGann in November that Rob Porter's
security clearance was held up because
of allegations from two ex-wives Magan
learned of the charges from both the FBI
and an ex-girlfriend who also alleged
abuse Friday night a White House speech
writer David Sorenson resigned after a
news report detailed abuse is alleged by
his ex-wife Sorenson told CBS News he
was the one who was abused in a tweet on
Saturday President Trump seemed to side
with the accused people's lives are
being shattered and destroyed by a mere
allegation writing in Time magazine
Porter's second wife
Jenny Willoughby said the president's
words were quote meant to imply that I
am a liar that abuse is something to be
questioned and doubted we certainly wish
him well mr. Trump's defense of Porter
in the Oval Office last week brought
this retort from former Vice President
Joe Biden that's like saying that axe
murder out there he's a great painter
Porter had an interim security clearance
but President Trump
enlarged his responsibilities and gave
him more power even after concerns were
raised in the process of working through
his background check now more than a
dozen White House employees currently
operate under that interim security
clearance cover and one of them is the
president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
John Major thanks the White House
obviously we'd like to be talking about
something else this week the president
unveils an infrastructure plan what do
we know about that price tag one and a
half trillion dollars and after tax cuts
and a big spending deal that might
create some sticker shock on Capitol
Hill but the White House says don't
worry Congress only 200 billion dollars
will come from Washington the rest will
come from state and local governments
and the private sector Democrats say
wait a minute the federal government's
got to spend much more than that
the White House counters we have under
invested in infrastructure and by
accelerating the permitting process we
will attract private investment all of
that is to be teased out in the process
of negotiations with Congress Wednesday
here at the White House there'll be a
meeting to kick all of that off John all
right major thanks so much